[Aplausos]
[Música]
angela merkel es algo así como el rey
arturo de la política ahora que se
jubila parece que europa entera va a
quedar huérfana de verdad podemos
imaginarnos un futuro sin merkel muchos
de los que veáis este vídeo ni siquiera
tendréis recuerdos políticos de cómo era
europa antes de merkel hablamos de una
de las líderes democráticas que más
tiempo ha durado en el cargo 16 años
durante su carrera como canciller
alemana merkel ha conocido a cuatro
presidentes de los eeuu distintos y
dentro de alemania solo hay otro
político que haya durado tanto tiempo
como canciller hablamos de helmut kohl
pero no sólo eso además angela merkel
deja su cargo con una popularidad
envidiable el 76 por ciento de los
alemanes todavía confía en ella pese a
llevar tantísimo tiempo en el poder y
según todas las encuestas es la líder
mundial mejor valorada en el resto de
países dicho de otra forma que puede
gustarnos más o menos angela merkel pero
hay algo indudable nuestros hijos la van
a estudiar en los libros de texto así
que la comparación parece obvia estamos
ante una nueva marca de thatcher vale
mejor nunca os lo habéis planteado pero
os aseguro que dentro del equipo de
visual política hemos tenido esta
discusión millones de veces
[Música]
y si lo pensáis tiene sentido tanto
merkel como thatcher fueron las primeras
mujeres en presidir sus respectivos
países ambas militaban en partidos de
centroderecha ambas ganaron varias
elecciones y ambas se consolidaron como
grandes líderes mundiales la diferencia
es que thatcher siempre tuvo un perfil
algo más polarizante en el caso de
merkel podemos decir que todo el mundo
desde la izquierda hasta la derecha la
quiere el problema el problema es que
todos la quieren como amigas 26 de
septiembre de 2021 los socialdemócratas
se imponen por poco a la alianza de
angela merkel en las históricas
elecciones alemanas habéis oído bien
cuando margaret thatcher dejó el poder
los británicos volvieron a elegir un
candidato de su mismo partido el
conservador john major sin embargo
merkel no ha conseguido que su sucesor
vuelva a ganar las elecciones entendedme
no es que los alemanes estén del todo
decepcionados con ella pero digamos que
han tenido suficiente con 16 años de
democracia cristiana en este vídeo vamos
a repasar las principales luces y las
principales sombras de merkel que ha
hecho mal esta mujer o que no ha hecho
también cuál es el legado de angela
merkel como la vamos a recordar hoy para
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
dejadme que os hable del nuevo canal en
el que colabora visual politics si lo
hubiera sabido
[Música]
en este canal y de la mano de
mutuactivos vais a descubrir todos los
secretos del mundo de las finanzas por
ejemplo cómo podemos proteger nuestros
ahorros utilizando los mercados
financieros o qué es eso de la inversión
en sg o cómo podemos invertir en
megatendencias todas estas preguntas y
muchas más se responden en si lo hubiera
sabido esperamos que os guste y que lo
disfrutéis y ahora si vamos a ver un
poco de historia
[Música]
noto que es lo que funciona
para entender bien el legado político de
merkel tenemos que entender la herencia
que le dejó el anterior canciller alemán
hablamos del socialdemócrata gerhard
schroeder
[Música]
y si el nombre os va a sonar a muchos
sobre todo a los que seáis veteranos
seguidores de visual polític porque en
este canal hemos hablado bastante de
este señor y normalmente para mal porque
si mis queridos amigos de visual
polítiques ryder fue el canciller de
alemania y después ha estado trabajando
para la gasística rusa gazprom pero
seamos honestos aunque schroeder sea
actualmente el hombre de putin en europa
hay que reconocer que no fue un mal
canciller para alemania
[Música]
uno de sus grandes logros fue la agenda
social 2010 una especie de macro reforma
laboral pensada para que alemania
saliera de la crisis en la que estaba
hablamos de principios del siglo 21 por
aquel entonces alemania estaba
considerada como el enfermo de europa el
paro estaba por encima del 8% así que en
la reforma laboral de schroeder incluía
grandes liberalizaciones flexibilización
de las medidas flexibilización de las
formas de contrato y todas esas cosas
que suelen enfadar a los sindicatos esta
vez no fue distinto la oposición a la
que se enfrentó a shriver fue tan
bestial que en el año 2005 perdió una
moción de censura si amigos de visual
política la reforma elaborada alemana le
costó nada menos que el cargo al señor
schroeder así es como en el año 2005
alemania celebró elecciones anticipadas
y así es como entra en escena la
protagonista de este vídeo 11 de octubre
de 2005 merkel se convierte en la
primera mujer canciller de alemania y
diréis que ocurrió nada mas merkel llegó
al poder pues que todo este paquete de
reformas laborales que acababa de
aprobar el anterior gobierno empezó a
surtir efecto no me creéis pues he
echado un vistazo
[Música]
como podéis ver el primer año tras la
aprobación de la agenda social 2010 el
desempleo llegó a su pico pensando así
las reformas no actúan inmediatamente
pero a partir del año 2005 el paro
empieza a bajar dicho de otra forma
schrader sufrió la parte mala de hacer
políticas impopulares que es pues que
son políticas impopulares merkel sin
embargo se quedó con la parte buena y es
que esas políticas muchas veces
funcionan pero no sólo eso pensadlo bien
la economía alemana es una de las más
diversificadas del mundo la alemania
tiene miles de casos como este alemania
cuenta con miles de empresas medianas
que son líderes en su nicho de mercados
en muchos casos no hablamos de empresas
famosas pero por ejemplo alguna vez os
habéis planteado quién fabrica las
suelas de los zapatos que lleváis ahora
mismo pues muy probablemente la suela de
goma de vuestro zapato esté fabricada
con una máquina fabricada por una
empresa que se llama desmán no la
conocen ni en su casa pero dentro de su
nicho es el líder mundial
[Música]
y esto combinado con las políticas
laborales de reder llegó a que alemania
sobreviviera a la gran crisis financiera
de 2008 mucho mejor que ningún otro país
y quien gobernaba alemania por aquel
entonces
exacto angela merkel por supuesto que
con esto no queremos quitarle todo el
mérito el hecho de no tocar lo que ya
funciona es algo digno de aplauso pero
no solo hablamos de economía en realidad
otra de las grandes apuestas de merkel
fue la política energética veréis desde
los años 80 alemania es uno de los
países más anti nucleares del mundo y de
hecho el canciller gerhard schröder como
buen izquierdista quería cerrar todos
los reactores nucleares del país como os
podéis imaginar
merkel como buena derechista estaba
totalmente en desacuerdo atentos a lo
que decía en el año 2009 22 de
septiembre del 2009 merkel a la
defensiva sobre la energía nuclear
angela merkel la canciller alemana está
haciendo campaña para revertir la
decisión de eliminar la energía nuclear
antes de 2021 si su opción de coalición
de centroderecha llega al poder sin
embargo eso es lo que defendía en 2000
porque dos años más tarde japón sufrió
el accidente de fukushima
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
pero que tiene que ver japón con
alemania pues si nos vamos a los
detalles técnicos en realidad muy poca
cosa pero como ya sabéis los detalles la
ciencia y los datos importan bastante
poco en política para el año 2011 ser
pronuclear en alemania era totalmente
impopular atentos 26 de marzo de 2011
cientos de miles de personas protestan
contra la energía nuclear en toda
alemania sin amigos de visual política
así es como merkel pasó de defender la
energía nuclear a anunciar el cierre de
las nucleares lo antes posible hoy en
día alemania ha pagado ya casi todos sus
reactores nucleares a día de hoy sólo
quedan seis en este caso hablamos de una
política que ha sido muy popular pero
que como muchos políticos que son muy
populares ha tenido unas consecuencias
catastróficas
[Música]
por un lado al dejar la energía nuclear
alemania ha tenido que quemar más carbón
que nunca segundo alemania ha tenido que
recurrir al gas natural que viene de
donde sea rusia de todo esto hemos
hablado en profundidad en muchos otros
vídeos de visual político pero en líneas
generales podríamos definir la política
energética de alemania como el populismo
tranquilo si es cierto merkel siempre ha
sido honesta y nunca ha dado grandes
discursos pasionales pero en muchos
casos se ha dejado enviar más por las
encuestas de opinión que por los datos
científicos pero de nuevo por suerte
para merkel las consecuencias de su
política energética no la sufrirá ella
sino que la sufrirá su predecesor
atentos 20 de septiembre de 2021 los
hogares alemanes se enfrentan a una
subida del 11,5 por ciento en la factura
del gas pero eso es tema para otro vídeo
porque ahora vamos a adentrarnos en otro
aspecto fundamental de angela merkel su
papel en la política internacional vamos
a verlo
de hacer acuerdos
para entender bien a merkel tenemos que
entender un concepto muy importante en
política el llamado capital político el
capital político es la credibilidad que
tiene un líder frente a otros votantes u
otros líderes esta credibilidad se puede
invertir para tomar decisiones más o
menos arriesgadas o para persuadir a
otros políticos para llegar a acuerdos
pues bien podríamos decir que angela
merkel es la 10 veces del capital
político por ejemplo tenemos el caso de
la eurocrisis del año 2011 recordáis que
alemania era uno de los países que había
salido mejor parado de la crisis
financiera por hacer una comparativa
cuando españa estaba superando el 26 por
ciento de paro alemán y estaban atentos
en el 24 por ciento
[Música]
por aquellos años los países del sur de
europa eran conocidos como los picks
acrónimo de portugal italia grecia y
españa- estos cuatro países necesitaban
financiarse pero los mercados exigían
intereses altísimos porque no se fiaban
de que podrían recuperar las deudas así
que sólo tenían una alternativa pedir
ayuda a la unión europea y cuál es la
economía más grande de europa que además
estaba en una de las mejores situaciones
exacto a alemania- y quien era la
canciller alemana en aquel momento
exacto 9 de octubre de 2012 los
manifestantes se concentran mientras
merkel expresa su apoyo a la grecia
afectada por la austeridad y así es como
nació la leyenda de merkel la campeona
de la austeridad y diréis pero qué
significa esto de la austeridad pues
básicamente merkel estaba dispuesta a
prestar el dinero a los países del sur
de europa con intereses muy bajos
ahora bien exigía que estos mismos
países se comprometieron a devolverlo y
para eso tenían que demostrar que iban a
recortar gastos
[Música]
si es algo muy loco pero como os podéis
imaginar estos son medidas muy
impopulares porque ningún político
quiere tener que despedir a funcionarios
por ejemplo y así es como de la noche a
la mañana todos los europeos nos
encontramos con cientos de caricaturas
de merkel como esa malvada alemana
estricta que quiere obligar a los pobres
políticos españoles y griegos a
apretarse el cinturón y diréis de verdad
llegaron a aceptar la austeridad los
pigs pues sobre el papel si ahora bien
en realidad hay muchos matices que hacer
por aquí por ejemplo españa se
comprometió a hacer recortes a la vez
que hacían cosas como esta 15 de junio
de 2013 madrid2020 presenta su
candidatura olímpica en suiza habéis
oído bien mientras españa prometía que
no iba a derrochar más dinero madrid-
quería organizar nada menos que unos
juegos olímpicos que como todo el mundo
sabe son del todo menos baratos que por
cierto iban a ser los juegos olímpicos
de 2020 los que casi arruinan a japón
así que menuda bala esquivó españa en
cualquier caso de verdad consiguió
merkel seducir al sur de europa con la
austeridad pues de nuevo si y no algunos
países como portugal sí que han seguido
a su manera la receta merkeliano grecia
muchas comillas ha aplicado algunos
recortes pero ni españa ni italia han
llegado a abrazar esa dichosa austeridad
[Música]
dicho de otra forma que al final la
europa rica terminó haciendo una
transferencia de capital sin casi
condiciones la pregunta es hizo un buen
acuerdo merkel o tal vez podría haberle
sacado más partido a su capital político
todo esto lo dejamos a la opinión de
cada uno pero lo cierto es que ésta no
ha sido la única gran crisis liderada
por merkel atentos 2 de agosto de 2016
el número de refugiados solicitando
asilo en europa se eleva al récord de
1,3 millones en 2015 la guerra de siria
se saldó con millones de refugiados
llamando a las puertas de europa y así
es como se inició uno de los debates más
intensos de la unión europea hasta qué
punto se puede aceptar a tanta gente que
viene sin trabajo y con una cultura tan
distinta en este caso merkel sí que lo
tenía claro 23 de abril de 2018 angela
merkel defiende que alemania acepte
10.000 refugiados de naciones unidas en
esta crisis markel se tuvo que enfrentar
a todos los países del este de la unión
europea pero también dentro de alemania
se encontró con muchos sectores que no
estaban tan a favor de aceptar a los
refugiados llegó a tener críticas
incluso dentro de su propio partido
pensando bien hablamos de miles de
refugiados a los que de repente hay que
darles de comer ponerles una casa y
enseñarles el idioma para que puedan
integrarse ya sabéis que aquí en visual
politics siempre hemos sido muy
partidarios de la inmigración pero las
cosas como son la crisis de los
refugiados tienen muchísimos matices y
es lógico que mucha gente se opusiera
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de hecho podría decirse que la postura
de merkel fue el empujón que necesitaba
la extrema derecha alemana para entrar
en el parlamento y desde entonces
alternativa por alemania es uno de los
partidos más importantes del país en
cualquier caso hay que reconocer que en
este caso merkel defendió sus principios
y consiguió que muchos otros países de
europa siguieran sus pasos la pregunta
es de verdad estaba siguiendo sus
principios o tal vez simplemente estaba
siguiendo las encuestas de opinión pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
porque merkel no es thatcher
i
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
llevamos varios minutos hablando de
merkel y todavía no hemos mencionado el
coronavirus exacto el broche de oro de
la administración de merkel ha sido su
gestión en la pandemia del coronavirus y
diréis pero por qué porque si nos
fijamos en los números de alemán ya
veremos que a ver no es que sean
especialmente malos pero tampoco son
especialmente buenos hay muchos otros
países como taiwán o corea del sur que
lo han hecho muchísimo mejor sin embargo
en un momento donde casi ningún líder
europeo ha dado la talla merkel parecía
ser la única que tenía una estrategia
clara no sólo eso ha sido uno de los
pocos casos de auténtica honestidad que
hemos visto cuando ha tenido que dar
malas noticias no ha dudado ni un
momento y vamos a reconocerlo todo esto
dibuja una personalidad y un estilo de
liderazgo envidiables y eso es
precisamente lo más destacable de angela
merkel queréis un modelo para seguir en
vuestra vida pues imitado a merkel
pero la pregunta la auténtica pregunta
es personalidad aparte cuál ha sido el
gran proyecto político de merkel y aquí
es donde es inevitable entrar de nuevo
en el terreno de las comparaciones ya sé
que las comparaciones son odiosas pero a
veces son necesarias y ahora es cuando
toca poner el perfil de angela merkel al
lado del perfil de margaret thatcher
[Música]
la primera gran diferencia es que
margaret thatcher nunca tuvo que
gobernar en coalición durante los 11
años que duró su administración thatcher
tuvo manga ancha para decidir por sí
sola merkel sin embargo nunca ha
gobernado en solitario primero se tuvo
que a liar con los socialdemócratas
después con los liberales y después con
los socialdemócratas de nuevo dicho de
otra manera que no le ha quedado más
remedio que hacer muchas concesiones
pero la pregunta sigue siendo que
principios tiene márquez quiero decir
podemos criticar muchas cosas del legado
de thatcher pero todos no sabemos cuáles
serán sus principios y sus líneas
generales y los defendió hasta el final
en el caso de merkel es que es casi
imposible entender cuál era su proyecto
político por ejemplo en el año 2015
merkel decía esto de los refugiados
si europa falla en la cuestión de los
refugiados entonces no será la europa
que deseamos angela merkel 31 de agosto
de 2015 sin embargo esto es lo que decía
la misma angela merkel cinco años antes
atentos 17 de octubre de 2010 angela
merkel el multiculturalismo alemán ha
fracasado estrepitósamente y ya sé lo
que me diréis mucho saber fonseca que
todo el mundo tiene derecho a cambiar de
opinión y si es cierto la pregunta es
hablamos de un cambio de opinión o de un
intento de contentar a los votantes algo
parecido nos encontramos con su política
energética cuando merkel se presentaba a
sus primeras elecciones su partido
defendía mantener las centrales
nucleares pero bastaron unas pocas
manifestaciones y unas encuestas de
opinión para que de un día para otro
merkel anunciara el cierre de todos los
reactores
[Música]
y no creáis que hablamos de un tema
menor sin energía nuclear alemania tiene
que depender aún más del gas natural y
como ya sabéis si seguís visual
políticas y todo ese gas natural viene
de la madre rusia es más recordáis ayer
heart is rather decíamos que no se puede
entender a merkel sin entender las redes
y lo cierto es que la carrera de estos
dos políticos ha ido siempre de la mano
porque justo ahora en el año 2021 los
intereses de schroeder que trabaja para
gazprom y los de merkel se han vuelto a
juntar
[Música]
10 de septiembre de 2021 gazprom anuncia
que el gasoducto nord stream 2 hacia
alemania está terminado por cierto que
si queréis conocer todos los detalles de
este proyecto tenéis un vídeo donde
hablamos del nord stream 2 con todos los
detalles os lo dejo en la descripción y
ya os digo desde aquí que dudo mucho que
los ucranianos tengan mucho cariño hacia
markel más bien todo lo contrario el
nord stream 2 ha hecho que alemania y
que toda europa dependa aún más de rusia
y dé la espalda a ucrania y todo ello
por una política energética que no
estaba respaldada por ningún dato
científico tan sólo aritmética política
y aritmética parlamentaria
[Música]
dicho de otra forma no podemos negar que
merkel ha tenido un carisma y una
capacidad de adaptarse a los
acontecimientos digna de aplauso ahora
bien realmente ha tenido un proyecto
político claro pues eso es más bien
discutible pero ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros como creéis que
recordaremos a angela merkel que
elecciones deberían sacar los políticos
que aún siguen en activo de esta
lideresa podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
político sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a este canal
y dadle la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
recordad también visitar el canal de si
lo hubiera sabido en el que colaboramos
activamente si este vídeo os ha gustado
darle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]